ще раз представтесь я Начальник
відділення інспекторів прикордонної
служби прахівай Степан майор зачник
сергійвич Я Хочу наголосити що пан майор
тівник Степан правильно Сергій Вибачте
тівник Сергій на сьогоднішній день
робить незаконну спробу не допуска мене
для передану кордону в мене на руках і
він це бачив є розпорядження голови
Верховної Ради для відрядження на
підставі цього розпорядження мною
заплановано
реалізація державницьких заходів у
вигляді двосторонніх і багатосторонніх
зустрічй в тому числі я довів що ця
зустріч спікером конгресу Сполучених
Штатів Америки від рішення якого
залежить виділення Україні 61 млрд в
тому числі з керівниками комітетів
конгресу і сенату в тому числі з
керівництвом пентагону в тому числі з
керівництвом державного департамента в
тому числі з
віце-президентами єврокомісії в тому
числі з лідером консервативної партії
Великої Британії і на сьогоднішній день
рішенням пана Майора яким Він визнає не
тісним сфальсифікованим або
скасованим рішення розпорядження голови
Верховної Ради Причому я його про
формувавши відповідно до закону про
регламент розпорядження голови Верховної
Ради не може бути скасовано або
змінено інакше крім як голосуванням
Верховної Ради констиційною більшістю
складу Верховної Ради тобто 226
депутатів сьогодні 1 грудня сьогодні
10та річниця Революції гідності коли
силовики атакували демократію силовики
атакували наш шлях єро єпейський Союз ці
два тижні Які в нас попереду визначальні
для долі України тому що для нас
принципово щоб Україна отримала зброю
амуніцію і гроші і я хотів довести пану
майору що він виконуючи злочинні накази
тому що я впевнений що прикордонники тут
не до чого і багато з них на фронті
зараз виконують надзвичайно важливі
завдання а ці позиції - це позиції офіса
президента офіс президента для якого
війна вже закі ся офіс президента для
якого атака на єдність вони всі
займаються виборами і сьогодні є
недопуск лідера опозиції Хочу наголосити
що на зовнішніх ринках ми маємо бути
єдині ми маємо виступати держав і я хочу
звернутися до наших партнерів бо я
вимушений їх зараз проінформувати щоби
цей ганебний приклад демократичної
поведінки який паплюжить Україну ні в
якому разі не вплинув на прийняття
рішення про надання нам фінансування
прийняття рішень про
відкриття переговорів
про вступ України до ЄС тому що це все
як і Беркут 10 років тому ідуть а
Україна буде в ЄС в НАТО і демократичною
дош для того щоби не використовувались
залежні від
них преставники силових Пей не закон
Тому що йому доведено що народний
депутат керується виключно конституцією
і законами України ніякими пдзаконними
актами діяльність народного депутата не
може бути обмежна Ну тим більше що є
розпорядження голови Верховної Ради
показують пісульку що хтось намагається
його скасувати
е незаконно і в даному випадку Я Хочу
наголосити що
е зараз із-за цього про Україну питання
будуть вирішуватися без України тому що
я єдиний доповідач на
idu - це Міжнародний демократичний форум
це міжнародна найавторитечніша
інституція в світі де представлена
республіканська партія Сполучених Штатів
де представлена європейська Народна
Партія і пан майор позбавляє Україну
можливості брати там у